yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Boris that Boris that second
check if he actually plays Oh he places
the singing but with a funky sideline
wow that's the kind of thing where you
should better remember who goes back
okay you know I have no clue what to do
that cannot be terrible I just wonder
even if this is if this is transposing
into some sort of accelerated dragon
like after Queen D form knight c6 and g6
it's very close I should have played
that quicker I mean I mean this is
definitely a playable position for white
and playing it quicker would have made a
lot of sense okay
hmm that looks odd
what is this idea there and how do you
avoid material losses the bishop is just
hanging there
yeah you have to do that okay now when
two resigns that's quick really is it
that bad I mean it is bad but what is
that come on how do I get rid of that no
okay so there wasn't really that that
would be a very short video right yeah
but anyway maybe it's interesting for a
little bit of opening talk so Knight c3
Knight c7 is an odd move I've never seen
that one before yeah I mean what black
usually does he is to take on c3 or play
six I can tell you what I know I know
that if he takes pawn takes that this
has been played in some games in recent
years there's a game Carlton
Grundy Leo's for example that I remember
and I only remember that white is better
by playing normal moves just cover this
pawn it is a little bit more complicated
than that other I mean grandi Leo's
didn't play just to be worse he had some
ideas but for such a rare line that's
all you probably need to know keep that
space advantage and and the more
complicated line is e six in some way
here it's an interesting choice in fact
um when I analyzed this line from I keep
it simple one year for repertoire I
could door them I only looked at Knight
takes d5 which is better for white it's
just a very long line yeah I still
analyze that I gave it in the book and
later I picked up a book by John Shaw
one of his efore repertoire books where
he recommended the move Knight e4 as a
simple solution to prove a right
advantage and he's right - Shaw is right
that is better for white and it's
relatively simple to remember so
now if I would do it again I would
probably also recommend the move in any
case if you look at this
you will actually see that white is
better it is just a bit it takes a bit
of yeah it takes a bit of memory that
you have to you have to memorize some
stuff so that's it's and that's a
sentence that does make some sense so 96
this is the line this Queen b6 and this
is where you need to remember that your
books that you have to go pick up C form
take I mean it's not like super
difficult yeah to to remember all this
but it's yeah you have to have to do it
94 check I think 195 that is also
possible am 95 95
night f7 night f7 rook f7 Queenie six
check take take take take and what has
the better ending something like that
and it's a it's really it's a pain to
play that I'm like it's suffering here
the whole game but it's like seventeen
moves and you know I kind of make it
made it work but it's not not the
easiest thing in the world if you have
looked at this like years ago so 94 is a
good alternative but that is better for
white okay he played 97 I went deform
take take take take
and I think g6 now is a transposition to
to align from them from the accelerated
dragon that is not so bad for black as
as far as I know this is why I was
thinking it a little bit with the move
deformed the line I'm referring to is
this one tink tink Knight f6 5 I'm
actually a tempo up because like this
this this this I'm a tempo up here this
black smooth and it would if he would
play g6 it's my move so I don't go
Knight to Queen a4 and Queenie 4 so ok
it is the same kind of position type but
it's a tempo and the tempo in such a
position makes a huge difference yeah ok
so Knight c7 is probably then correctly
answered by default opening up the
position ok still if you play something
yeah not to d5 let's say it is a game
iam and this is just not good the engine
recommends Queen to beef
what kind of move is that take
oh here you have to play King to the
tomb that is not okay so I do understand
like here but should be five yeah and
killing yeah because this is leading to
to mate very nice okay it's it's it's
okay you can find that you know you know
if you have some time on the clock
yeah he went in five and resigned at the
same time okay I would have taken with
the night and there is I mean black
continue to travel but not like you use
a piece immediately plus three okay
white wins but it was still an early
resignation okay guys it was a very
short game but maybe still some useful
information about the opening thanks a
lot for watching